– Mein Vater.
Er hat irgendwie herausgefunden,
dass ich nicht beim Sprachkurs bin.
Er ist total sauer!
– Was? Aber ... wie?
– Keine Ahnung, Nico. Ich muss gehen.
– Ich denke nicht, dass er irgendetwas ahnt.
– Ich glaube schon. Es tut mir leid!
– Hey, Nico.
Wo will Selma denn hin?
Ich soll dich von ...
Herrn Al-Pascha grüßen, ihrem Vater.
Ich hab grad mit ihm telefoniert.
– Du hast was?
– Ich hab mit Selmas Vater telefoniert.
– Und ihm gesagt, dass wir hier sind.
– Ja.
– Du weißt nicht, was du gemacht hast!
Du bist so ein Idiot!
– Spinnst du?
– Es war alles in Ordnung.
Dann kommst du, Selma kriegt Riesenärger
und du bist schuld!
– Ich find nicht,
dass ich an irgendwas Schuld hab.
Was ist denn eigentlich dein Problem?
– Selmas Eltern denken,
dass sie beim Deutschunterricht ist.
Sie darf sich nicht mit mir treffen.
– Seid ihr beiden … zusammen?
– Nein, wir sind nur Freunde,
aber das ist jetzt vielleicht alles vorbei.
– Nico, das ist mir echt ...
Es tut mir leid. Ich wusste das nicht.
– Halt dich einfach aus meinem Leben raus!